les décors ajouré
le décor de bois découpé est apparue
tardivement dans l'architecturé créole
c'est durant la seconde moitié du 19e
siècle mais plus probablement encore au
début du xxème siècle que free
ornementale garde corps et un poste à
jour et viennent décorer les maisons
réunionnaise inspiré d'éléments en fonte
de faire mouler ouest en paix ses décors
sont aussi directement influencée par l'
architecture qui se développe en europe
au milieu du 19e siècle notamment en
france et en angleterre
le plus ancien des corps en bois découpé
de la réunion se trouve sur la face à
l'ouest de l'ancienne maison fou rue
jules auber à saint denis
parmi les éléments traditionnels de
décor le losange figures géométriques
simples s'est lui aussi imposé au fil du
temps le décor le plus emblématique
reste toutefois le lambrequins sa
réalisation suit la fantaisie des
artisans et les exigences des
propriétaires plus riches sur le devant
des maisons
ils sont souvent plus modestes sur les
côtés des formes géométriques les plus
simples hassan aspiré par la nature
environnante les frises de lambrequins
keyboard toiture varangue et au vent
contribuer introduire une note de
fantaisie
contrastant avec l'aspect rustique des
maisons créoles d'apparition tardive
dans l'histoire de l'architecturé
réunionnaise le décor en bois ou en
métal découpé est aujourd'hui considéré
comme l'un des symboles les plus
représentatives de l'architecturé créole